we don't have a mythology we would say
we can justify the existence of god
from first principles which is a
different conversation for a different
time
all right so what are the entailments of
social contract and this is a key point
here in the discussion
because we talked about human rights and
some of the questions we're asked as
muslims relate to fundamental human
rights
so for example equality of men and women
this is
by the way according to what strand of
feminism second wave feminism
third wave feminism you know first wave
feminism even
what do we mean by equality according to
who's feminism is it the eurocentric
understanding of feminism
is that an african feminism is it a
middle eastern fem
that's a different discussion but they
say also that we have to have
freedom of expression of whatever
religious belief you want
to what extent though because obviously
society even in this country and other
countries has decided that there are
certain kinds of things which can't
exist which jeopardize security and so
on
so the question is when now we've come
out of the state of nature
from a liberal perspective we've come
out of the state state of nature
and we're socially contracted to this
representative which in modern parlance
would be referred to as government right
when we're now we're we're tied to such
representative
the question is what are
the things this representative can do on
our behalf
this is a key thing and i want everyone
to remember this right
this is something which immanuel kant
which we said already was one of the
biggest philosophers in all of liberal
history but not only that but one of the
biggest philosophy of all western
history
he basically says i'm not going to read
this whole thing you can you can kind of
read it yourself
he basically says that if the supreme
sovereign this socially contracted thing
or body or government or whatever it is
they can that has pretty much ultimate
authority
even if he decides to kill you or kill
some people or
jail some people or hurt some people
there's a there's a hadith inside muslim
that says
which some people make fun of that you
know you've got to be obedient to the
leader even if he
whips your back or takes your money
obviously there's such a big discussion
on this we're not having in that
discussion but
this is the same kind of thing in
liberal theory
so in liberal theory it's conceivable
that there is a law which so
limits which so limits
human freedoms so as to allow someone to
be killed as a result
and john locke says in one of his books
i think it's the two truths of
government he says
if someone is commanded to stand in the
face of a cannon
if a soldier is commanded to stand in
the face of a cannon
yes in other words a blowing cannon he
should do it
and it's not illiberal for someone to do
that which is kind of like suicide
bombing by the way
think about that no seriously it's this
what is that you know tell me what that
is
standing in the face of a cannon is
destroying yourself it's killing
yourself suicide
so according to john locke and by the
way also according to john rules
who says that you can kill innocents by
the way this is what he says
he says you can kill innocents in war
it's just war you can kill you can
target the innocent
not collateral damage no you can target
them
so you can not only be subject to a
suicide
type scenario according to john locke
but all the way through
to john rules who said you not only can
be subject to such scenario
but you can subject others to such
scenario as well
in other words you can kill children if
it goes back to the social contract
and if it goes back to the mandated
legitimate sovereign leader
who we have been socially contracted to
in this mythological state of nature
bearing that in mind the question now is
what's the relevance of this and
apostasy well you know the liberal would
ask what is this thing
that you guys have in your old books of
of jurisprudence and i said in the
beginning of the lecture
that when i describe i'll be defining
what islamic
traditionalism is so i'll do it quickly
now islamic traditionalism to me
is a jurisprudential understanding of
islam
for example through the four schools of
thor in sunni islam
for example right so that's my
understanding of
islamic traditionalism so obviously if
you open a book of islamic
law which is like a classical book
and you go to maybe the you know kitable
ginayet or something like that
you might see this the punishment of
apostasy
and you'll see that some of those
scholars will say the one who changes
his religion
you know they should be killed in an
islamic state
and you think wait a minute doesn't this
strongly oppose human rights and on the
face of it it does
strongly oppose human rights and this is
not
on the face of it prima facie what we
believe in anyway
this is and deconsexualized
understanding of islamic law and i'll
explain that in a second but what's
interesting is this
so long as something is justified
through a social contract
on liberalism look what john locke is
saying
john locke who is the founding father of
liberalism
says that there can be
an apostasy law
wait a minute what does he say he says
the first is those of who
being initiated in the mosaic right he's
talking about the jewish
states or jewish states and made
citizens of that commonwealth
did afterwards apostasize means become
from the worship of the god of israel
these were preceded against
as traitors and rebels guilty of no less
than
high treason listen to this no
less than high treason for the
commonwealth of the jews
different in that from all others was an
absolute theocracy nor was there or
could there be
any difference between that and the
commonwealth of the church
now what does this mean what's he trying
to say he's saying because
the the state of the jews is predicated
on your contracting with god
and you're being jewish in the first
instance
that it's justifiable on liberalism
listen to this carefully it's
justifiable on
liberalism from this social contract
understanding
that if someone publicly says i'm not a
jew anymore
for the state to say come hold here come
here we're going to execute you
now is that what the quran says the
quran doesn't make this kind of
articulation by the way this is what
john lok says
who is the founding father of liberalism
so how conceivable is it
how conceivable is there on liberalism
that these laws can be put in place it
is fully conceivable
in principle now one could argue that
was john locke
that was 300 years ago we're no longer
looking at luck
my argument is not about john locke he
is looking at the conceivability
through the principles of liberalism
i am saying because the principles of
liberalism
through social contract allow such
possibilities
you cannot argue that liberalism is
against
a public apostasy law which
would entail a death of a person you
cannot argue that
it's impossible to argue that you could
argue as a liberal i'm not really
you know in tune with that and i think
it ought not to be
but if a country decides if a country
decides for example
that this country is not a secular
country not this country obviously it is
but we're talking about a country like
you know a jewish
state not talking about israel that's a
different discussion
but if it decides okay this is not we're
not our social contract
is not a secular one it's a
theocracy of some sorts let's say for
the sake of arguing or it's something
which is predicated on religious
scriptures
if that's the case the question is how
illiberal is it on social
contractarianism
to have such law john locke answers in
fact
this is not illiberal at all and not
only would john locke say that
emmanuel kant would say that i've seen
manuscripts of john stuart mill saying
that
it's quite consistent so
the question now is what does islam have
to say about that
but before i go into that question about
apostasy in islam
there's an argument i want to make and
the main argument is articulated
here because this is part of my book
i've actually written a book here it's
coming out maybe the end of the year
yes yes i've been doing the research
by the way this is not something i just
whipped up this i've spoken to a lot of
academics about this
all right my main argument liberalism or
liberalization efforts
are epistemologically fruitless
if they are predicated on the assumption
that
such liberalization necessarily entails
more freedom
from government interventionism in cases
which relate
to administration of the death penalty
for non-allegiance to a state now that's
a very long-winded statement
but you have to be careful with
academics what i'm saying is
there is something similar between
for example that which is referred to as
the haddo
which is the what is referred to as the
punishment for apostasy
and treason and the common denominator
is
non-allegiance to a state so for example
if you look at the american constitution
if my memory serves me correctly i think
article three talks about
the treason it's a clause on treason
treason clause
and basically what it says is the future
of non-allegiance
different states have different rules in
america it could be punishable
and has been punishable by death and by
the way
what's interesting is as a side note in
terms of actual case study examples
you'll find that america has conducted
many extrajudicial
killings outside of obviously the
parameters of the judiciary as you know
for example
many of you may have heard of anwar
laulaki yes
his son was killed his name is abdul
rahman al-awlaki
and his daughter was also killed they
were kids by the way
they were killed by a drone attack on
them yes
them why because the american government
were afraid
because okay their father is a radical
the child will also grow up to be
a radical right so they literally sent
little drones
to kill the kids now that wasn't those
kids didn't
deserve to be killed and no moreover
they didn't even stand trial
if that was possible for a child to
stand trial at the age of six years old
or whatever it may have been anyway
so the question of extrajudicial killing
is something completely different anyway
i'm talking about when the treason law
itself has been implemented and what's
interesting if you look at
constitutional law in america
is that those defendants who are subject
to such
encroachments from the military
establishment in america
actually try and get the treason law to
be enacted on them in other words they
try and
a lot of them argue that we want to be
tried in accordance with the treason law
because they know they have more chance
of being not killed for example in in
that case
but there have been those extra judicial
killings now that's something else the
point is this it's conceivable
principally
it is conceivable principally that a
government because it
deems you as non-ally now
you're no longer a citizen depriving you
of your citizenship and so on
they can make a subsequent decision to
kill you
and it has been done but it's just been
named something else
this is the point now the truth is this
in islam
you have to first ask what is apostasy
and what is treason
right now who gets to define treason now
someone might argue treason is this and
they'll go online and you know this
pseudo-intellectual approach oh treason
means this listen spare your white man
definitions
keep them to yourself seriously who
wrote the dictionary
who was it was it someone who we all
agreed this is the authority yes let him
be the one no come on be let's be honest
oxford dictionary webster dictionary no
it wasn't something which we all
as humankind decided yes this is no no
vernacular definitions from the
dictionary are fruitless to me
you can't use a secular definition
impose it on a religious framework
and explain try and explain things that
way
treason is defined differently yes
because you have a secular framework
versus a religious one
why should you impose a secular
framework on a religious one
as much as why would you impose a
religious foreign secular one
they both have two different standards
right
however the principle of non-allegiance
is the same so in other words really and
truly what is the common denominator
when a state deems that you're no longer
allied now here's the point
is it to do with what you believe now i
would
put to you submit to everyone here today
that is not to do with what you believe
and the evidence is not like
that there's no compulsion in religion
there is that that's for the non-muslims
by the way that verse by jamal is for
the non-muslims there's no compulsion in
religion
chapter 2 verse 256 means you can't
force a non-muslim to become muslim
but what about me
sorry i've recited that quickly but
where it says it's not for a man or a
woman
who's a muslim or a mutman that when
allah and his messenger decide something
that they have any choice in the matter
the point is this even then it's not to
do with belief
and it's conceivable and possible for
someone to lose faith in their religion
as a muslim in an islamic govern
government state or whatever you want to
call it i'm not talking about those
things which exist
but it's conceivable and they would have
no repercussion whatsoever
it's not to do what's the evidence for
that two pieces of evidence
one of them is the the list of them
had a list of people who are
someone who does not believe really in
islam he does not believe in islam
that's the true understanding of money
yes he might walk around in society and
not necessarily publicate
that he's left islam but he does not
disbelieve in he doesn't believe in
islam that list
even though muslims were aware that
those people were not muslims
they didn't kill those individuals
because there was no rupture of the
social contract there
in other words it's conceivable now if
someone in the west becomes
non-muslim and they were muslim we're
not going to say go and kill that
individual no way
this is an understanding of islam which
is orientalist
decontextualized and completely wrong in
my opinion there's no way you can do
that
because there was no contract between
you and that person that okay you are
now
allied to that state in that way there's
no state in fact the state here
says you can do whatever you want and
you can have whatever belief you want so
in fact their contract is different to
your contract the quran says
those all you who believe fulfilled the
contract so in other words there is no
contract there there has to be a
contract you have to be under an islamic
state and you have to have agreed to the
terms
if those conditions are not met then we
can't say there's any
going to be any ramification
now another point is this is that you
have and this is one of the final points
i'm going to make
is that you have another example and
this is one of the biggest
hadith in sahara bukhari it's in kitab
the book of conditions and then you have
a discussion between prophet muhammad
and the quraish
and and the quraish was saying if
listen to this carefully if
your people in in your state become
non-muslim
bring them back to us do you agree to
those terms and he agreed to those terms
say that one more time he said if people
in your state become non-muslim
under this contract that we have now
bring those guys who have left islam
apostated back to us he said no problem
he agreed to those conditions meaning
what really this what this means
is that it's totally conceivable
both on islam and liberalism for there
to be some kind of social contract which
would bind somebody
to a state of being now
even if they decide to change their
religion it's conceivable on both
liberalism and islam
that it's not a problem and it's
conceivable on both liberalism and islam
that it could have ramifications
depending upon how it's perceived by the
state
now next
the reason why the the the topic today
was referred to as liberalism as
religion and this is a really
interesting quote
i'm going to read it out it says
theories of modernization are not
scientific hypotheses
but theodicies narratives of providence
and redemption presented in the jargon
of social science
what we're saying is that liberalism the
reason why it's been able to have this
perceived epistemological upper hand on
the religious narrative not just the
islamic one
it's because it seems like you're
speaking scientifically when you're
talking about secular ideology
what we've been able to show today
ladies and gentlemen is that that is not
the case
and that the the first principles of
liberalism are
unfounded unsubstantiated unproven
we've also been able to show ladies and
gentlemen that actually
not only are the the first principles
i'm proven but a lot of them are based
on mythology
fiction stories
and so on and so to favor that kind of a
narrative over and above the islamic
quran
or any other religious narrative for
that matter is frankly
academically unfair in the first
instance
epistemologically unjustified in the
first instance
philosophically unjust frankly you can't
do that
and ask us questions so before any
questions are asked
from a person who claims to be a liberal
who might be now thinking that they have
found the ultimate truth
how can you prove liberalism as an
objective moral standard number one
from a scientific perspective or
otherwise or from a rational first
principle perspective
number two why do you expect us to
believe in your myth
why even even your philosophers that
propounded that myth
didn't believe in it fully themselves
they didn't conduct any scientific
experiments
number three do you not realize that
it's as conceivable
on a contractarian understanding of
liberalism to have as much punitive law
as could conceivably be the case in an
islamic state with all of the punitive
laws being implemented
so if that is the case what do you have
to offer us
what is modernization why should we be
like you
what have you got for us the answer is
really you have nothing for us
sorry to say i need to be blunt you have
nothing to offer
liberalism has nothing to offer islam
that's the answer
it's there's nothing there for us
everything that's conceivable in
liberalism
can also be potentially conceivable in
islam and vice versa
in terms of punitive laws and so on so
what's the issue
now they'll say human rights human
rights and i'm going to say this once
and everyone should remember it
they human rights is a metaphysical
construct
which cannot be actualized in the real
world it's impossible to have
an actualization of human rights
with the existence of social contracts
you can never have ultimate freedom of
anything that's nonsense
on stilts as jeremy bentham said it's
impossible
now the the answer is this that liberals
will say
we define the extent to which freedom of
speech expression and so on thought and
religion should be exercised in the
state
in accordance with democracy or this or
that or the other
but those things themselves are
problematic because they number one
could be in conflict of liberalism
and number two could bring out results
like hitler
which had you know retrospectively
everyone looks back and says how
immoral was he in sum
therefore what i want to say is
the question needs to be questioned
whenever they ask you a question which
is predicated on human rights
you should say no thank you
you have to first justify yourself
the last thing here i've got sorry